good morning John so I'm sure you've
seen this clip of Keanu Reeves talking
to Stephen Colbert because we actually
talked about it so I I know that you
have but I'm gonna show it to you for
everybody else to what do you think
happens when we die
Keanu Reeves I know that the ones who
love us will miss us certain people
watching will no doubt be aware that Jon
you have like a thing for Keanu Reeves
and I want to start out by saying this
video is not a Keanu Reeves video I know
that John you someday you are going to
make your Keanu video that's not what
I'm doing right now I'm not gonna take
that away from you this video is just
about that one Stephen Colbert interview
nothing else he's uncle bear and Keanu
Reeves before this question is asked are
talking about the new Bill and Ted movie
which is actually the thing that's
happening very exciting so they're
talking about this silly silly movie I'm
like the universe ending if they can't
write a song and then Stephen Colbert
like asks one of the two or three
biggest questions that humanity has ever
faced as a joke obviously but the joke
kinda is that like of course this is a
silly thing to ask anyone on a Late Show
like this is a time for fun and levity
but the joke is also that it's kind of
not a weird question somehow to ask
Keanu Reeves like I don't really care to
hear most people's take on this question
like okay it's kind of boring we've been
through this I kind of want to know what
Keanu would say and not at itself is
something that's like weird and
interesting to examine like why do I
want to know what Keanu would say even
after a conversation where Keanu is
mostly talking about like action fight
scenes silliness what does it like to
fight on a horse it's fun like literally
right before Steven asks the big
question like cow who's making this face
like look at this face but here's the
thing Steven does not ask the
traditional big question which is what
happens to us when we die he asks what
do you think happens when we die all of
us hear that to us in there one because
it's like the big question and two
because it's the thing that we're
actually worried about he
who answers the question as asked what
happens when we die I know that the ones
who love us will miss us and then comes
my favorite part of this video not
Keanu's answer but the audience having
no idea what to do with this there is a
protocol for what is happening and the
reason that this land so hard is that
the protocol has been broken
we just had an on Late Show answer to a
Late Show question first you here like a
couple giggles because people were
expecting a funny answer to this
question cuz like how can you answer it
any other way then they realize it was a
sincere answer so they go with like the
sincere answer noise which is ah but
only a few of them most people are
sitting there in silence which I can
tell you is what I did on Sunday morning
when I watched this clip and then cried
alone in my bed and then the audience
eventually finds the right thing to do
which is just clap because Keanu just
did an amazing thing not only did he
like violate Late Show protocol in a
really clever interesting way he also
like answered the specific question that
Stephen Colbert was asking like the
exact wording but in a way the big
question - because ultimately maybe what
happens to us when we die isn't as
important as what happens to everybody
else
maybe that should be the thing that we
care about the thing that we think about
the thing that we connect with and maybe
turning these things out word instead of
inward would be a really a positive
thing for a lot of aspects of our lives
God dang it kion ooh that was good it
was so good John I see what you see in
this guy and I will see you on Tuesday